Next up you brought us an important story
from Inside Edition, Deborah.
Yeah, we did.
And this is something that really got people crazed
when we did this story,
there's a new way for naughty people to track you.
A lot of stalkers out there using a very common technology
for devious purposes.
And it's an AirTag, but this is all it is.
It's a tiny little device,
Apple started making it last spring
and they're used to track everything from your
wallet, your pocketbook.
I'll hold it still.
Yeah, you can put it on your luggage, right?
I put them on my dogs.
Did you? It's a smart idea.
Yeah, well Lucy got out in the woods the other day.
And so you were able to find her.
Yes.
With the Air Tracker?
No, it was before the Air Tracker.
Oh.
So I went and got the Air Tracker
'cause I thought I don't want this to happen again.
Okay, but how would you like it if somebody took this
Air Tracker and stuck it into your pocket right here?
I would not like that.
You would not like that
at all.
Unfortunately, people are using this technology
to do just that, to follow people, to stalk them.
And we did a story where this poor girl,
as you see on camera here, is trying to find the AirTag.
She knows it's in there, she finally found it
in the inside of her door, kind of behind the handle.
And the only way she knew that it was there,
it popped up on her phone, there's an AirTag somewhere
but it's really hard to find.
So does this memo on your phone come up
if you're not paired with it, is it a warning?
How does it function, Deborah?
So it comes up on your phone
and it says that an unknown accessory has been detected.
It has been moving with you for a while.
The owner can see the location.
So the owner can go on his phone,
he will see essentially, like the map,
that tells you how to get from point A to point B,
it's map of where you have been with this AirTag,
on your person or in your car.
Now Apple's been very clear about this,
they condemn this kind of misuse and they say to stay safe,
you will always get an alert on your phone
if you're anywhere near an unknown AirTag.
And if you've got an Android device
you can download the Track Detector
that Apple's put out there to be the same kind of alert.
Well, you know, there's so many good things
we get with technology,
but this is one of those scary things.
And it's freaking out Drew Barrymore right now,
I can see it on your face.
Well, I'm very glad to know about it.
I have to say, before you brought this story
to our attention, I did not know about it.
And now I feel very empowered
to understand what is happening.
So thank you, Deborah, seriously, Deborah.
And now we can all benefit from not being like,
oh, that's nothing.
Now we know what to look for.
So thank you.
You're welcome.
Ross, you have a story.
Yeah, well, next up, this is a change of topics.
We're gonna talk about Brazilian Butt Lifts.
For those of you who don't know what that is, the BBL,
it's one of the most popular cosmetic procedures
on the planet.
There were at least 40,000 performed last year alone,
but apparently it there's a black market
that's capitalizing on this demand
and it can be a huge health hazard.
It can even be deadly.
Deborah, what do you know about this?
This is another one of these stories that we've done
that's really scary.
If you say there's 40,000 that were done last year.
The death rate is one in 3000.
Now with normal cosmetic surgery, it's one in 50,000.
So it's a lot more risky.
Whoa.
So from your 40,000,
that's like statistically, 13 women died,
from having a butt lift done.
Wow.
And you're catching flies
in there, because I can tell you're shocked.
We actually went to one of these places
that we found advertising on Instagram.
we went undercover just to show exactly
how these operators worked.
This was an unlicensed person who was advertising
butt injections on Instagram, doing them,
they didn't even know what was inside the needle.
So some of these places,
they have chemicals like Fix A Flat.
Wait, what?
Yes,
when your tire goes flat, cement liquid,
you know that stuff that like fills in the cracks.
Experts say, do the research,
if they don't know what's in the needle
then you certainly don't don't wanna have anything done.
No.
Make sure you go to a board certified
medical professional,
make sure you understand the risk,
and maybe just embrace your backside
and love what the Lord gave you.
Well, yeah, Fix a flat, so scary.
I mean, hello, Fix a Flat is for tires,
it's not to fix your flat butt, right.
This is so crazy.
But I just have to say, I love the Drew Crime,
or I should say Inside Edition X Drew Crime, I love it.
I love doing this with you.
Let's do it more.
Please, please.
Yes, Deborah.
I love it.
Thank you.
Deborah, I love you so much.
Deborah Norville, Catch her on Inside Edition,
every week day, let's do this more.
Absolutely.
Inside Edition X Drew Crime.
(upbeat music)